I am taking so far as I'm at 4 a day astral clear at 3 a day and aroma clear at 3 a day. I am
having hot flashes. Should I take them at a certain time of the day, do the hot flashes
need anything bad? No, the hot flashes actually need that it's working, so you're using so far as I'm
which is a broccoli seed extract product an astral clear which is a lignet to help pull out
astrogens and aroma clear which is I see 3 and dim and something else to help pull out astrogens.
If you effectively pull out astrogens, you will have hot flashes. This is why people on
letrazole which is a rheumatase inhibitor don't like it because they're having hot flashes. How can
I prevent these hot flashes? Well, the hot flashes are really aside that they're really working,
so it's not that you can't prevent that really you that's what you're going to get when you
what you do, what you're trying to do.